Salut !
Tous les jours une énigme et une solution de l'énigme
Je commence à craquer car je suis en fin de tournage de ces vidéos
Une énigme par jour, pendant 32 jours
Et à chaque fois en début de vidéo, je vous donne la solution de l'énigme d'hier
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, allez la regarder parce que là la solution tiens en une seule phrase.
Et si vous l'entendez, vous ne pourrez pas la résoudre
C'est clair ce que je dis, je crois
La réponse à l'énigme d'hier est :
Qu'il faisait jour, tout simplement, c'est pour ça qu'il a pu la voir
J'aime beaucoup ce genre d'énigmes parce que comme on se focalise sur beaucoup de détails
On en fait une conclusion, mais une conclusion erronée
Qui tient sur rien... C'est simplement qu'il faisait jour !
Je vous laisse là-dessus et vous emmène tout de suite sur la prochaine énigme
Cette énigme N°18 m'a été inspiré par un ami à moi qui s’appelle JS, qui s’appelle Jean Sébastien
Jean Sébastien, si des fois tu regardes la vidéo, tu sauras pourquoi j'ai pensé à toi
L'énigme est la suivante :
Avant hier, JS avait 17 ans
L'année prochaine, il aura 20 ans
Comment est-ce possible ?
Je répéte : Avant hier, JS avait 17 ans, l'année prochaine il aura 20 ans
Comment c'est possible ?
Je vous donne un indice, ou plutôt un non-indice
Ça n'a rien à voir avec les années bissextiles
Ne cherchez pas de ce côté là, c'est pas ça du tout, c'est beaucoup plus logique que ça
Si vous trouvez la réponse, ne le dites pas dans les commentaires
Ou dites nous juste "J'ai trouvé", mais ne donnez pas la réponse
Pour pas dévoiler aux autres qui chercheraient, par contre laissez un pouce en l'air pour nous faire savoir que vous avez trouvé la réponse
Pensez également à vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
Et passez de BONNES VACANCES ! Rendez-vous demain à 17h ! Ciao !